I must have the perfect separation I'll
cream on one side no cream on the other
I found him
he's perfect I must go to him
I
you
dr. Oscar Bond yes is it you it is not
yes you are the distinct yes
the iJustine I've received your emails
you've got them then you know I am here
I'm here for the perfect step all cream
on one side it's all cookie on the other
you think you can learn how to do what I
do I've made it my life's work to get
that separation listen they all come and
they all say they want to learn but they
never want to share but I'll share prove
it
I've even brought some milk in my
suitcase
you brought milk I brought milk come I
will teach you
it is beautiful
you